I have come out here to this office
where I've been many times before and I
come out here today to apologize to the
people of New Jersey I apologize to the
people of Fort Lee and I apologize to
the members of the state legislature I
am embarrassed and humiliated by the
conduct of some of the people on my team
there's no doubt in my mind that the
conduct that they exhibited is
completely unacceptable and showed a
lack of respect for the appropriate role
of government and for the people that
were trusted to serve to pieces to what
I want to talk about today the first is
I believe that all of the people who
were affected by this conduct deserve
this apology and that's why I'm giving
it to them I also need to apologize to
them for my failure as the governor of
this state to understand the true nature
of this problem sooner than I did but I
believe I have an understanding now of
the true nature of the problem and I've
taken the following action as a result
this morning I've terminated the
employment of Bridget Kelly effective
immediately I terminated her employment
because she lied to me